voicemail number two one nine two david
p let's take a listen to this voicemail
that came in hi guys i'm calling i've
been a longtime fan of the show and I
really appreciate the commentary guys do
I just was wondering you know I've seen
this rise lately in these anti-feminist
anti sjw white supremacist red pill type
young white men and just online and
actually met a couple and I'm just
wondering I'm having a hard time you
know laughing my head around what's
going on inside these guys heads and I'm
wondering what you guys how you guys
would characterize because they're
psychopathology is going on inside these
guys head I'm curiously you guys think
yeah awesome right
listen I am NOT ready to characterize
the psychopathology of red peeled alt
writers but what I can tell you is we've
been following the movement for a long
long time we've got a number of pieces
about it including one about the alt
right check it out I would I would
hesitate pad to go into the
psychopathology of it yeah and
unfortunately as we talked about the
other day the people who most need to
see the pieces like our long-form alt
right piece aren't gonna be the ones
let's see it yes and if they do they're
certainly not going to be open to being
influenced by it alright great bonus
show today I'm out of time just trust me
folks trust me it's a good one